[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Старобільськ
Слобожанщина]
Ми зараз в центрі міста Старобільськ.
Батьківщина Сергія Жадана.
Це університет наш.
Тут я організовував «Бескінечна подорож»
або «Енеїда».
[Сергій Летучий
музикант, активіст Good library]
До нас приїжджали Оля Андрухович і Михарулюк... ось з «Артполя».
В бібліотеці локація замала,
тому ми робили тут, в цьому приміщенні.
Коли почались події у 2014 році —
багато було негативу на Схід України.
З приводу культури, з приводу різного...
Мало хто розумів людей зі Сходу.
Мало хто розуміє, як тут знищувалася
українська культура фізично,
тобто Луганська область знаходиться
близько до Росії,
ця машина просто все перемелює.
У нас було 3 голодомори і в мене бабуся —
в них з шести людей вижило двоє.
Дуже потужні патріоти були на Сході: це —
козаки і кобзарі, яких розістріляли в 1933 році.
Це голодомори і репресії,
тобто людей фізично знищували.
Це треба розуміти.
У 2015 році я познайомився з директором
і замдиректором бібліотеки.
Вони до нас приїхали в Старобільськ.
Мене так замотивувала ця історія, що їй 76 років,
і вона приїхала в Старобільськ
і хоче, щоб там була бібліотека.
Потім, у 2016 році мене запросили
працювати у бібліотеку.
Я познайомився з командою бібліотекарів: там було
декілька молодих і прикольних людей.
Я побачив для себе, що бібліотека — це більше, ніж книги.
І мені захотілося зробити бібліотеку
тим місцем, де можна збиратися молоді,
де можна реалізовувати проєкти,
проводити різні тусовки: літературні, освітні.
Де можна книгу прочитати і поговорити про книгу,
і обговорювати різні питання.
Такий вільний простір для вільних людей.
Я виїхала з Луганська, сиділа там до останнього.
Ніхто мені не казав, що робити,
люди продовжували стріляти, страшно.
[Інна Риб'янцева
провідна методистка Good library]
А працівники продовжують ходити на роботу.
Питаю в обласне управління:
«Що робити? Закрити бібліотеку чи що робити?»
«Ми не знаємо», — кажуть.
Це була якраз та ситуація, коли керівник приймає
рішення і потім несе за нього відповідальність.
Пишу приказ про те, що у зв'язку з таким
положенням, бібліотека припиняє свою діяльність.
І всі уходять... так, не знаю, що вони будуть робити.
Але знаєте, я так думала: цей наказ
буде дійсний місяць, ну може два.
Ми всі повернемося і все буде...
Але так сталося, що все затягнулось.
Але я сама собі сказала: якщо все так залишиться,
то я не зможу з цими людьми працювати.
Ніяк не зможу...
Так воно і сталось...
У мене не було і гадки туди повертатися.
Бібліотеку ми переєстрували
на вільній території в кінці 2015 року.
[Світлана Моісеєва
директорка Good library]
Почали одразу збирати бібліотечний фонд
спочатку і кинули такий клич:
«Ось бібліотека-переселенка, дайте нам книги!»
Нам допомагали відомі блогери,
то ми отримували книги майже кожен день.
Взагалі, були такі чуттєві моменти, коли нам хтось
з окупованого Луганська і казав, що:
«Ви — наша бібліотека, а не ті, що відкрилися там.
Я не можу Вам вислати книги тому, що не працює
там пошта. Можна Вам перерахувати гроші?»
Навіть таке було ! [сміється]
Пандус тут збудували.
Я робив проєкт у 2017 році...
Так трапилось, що я був у США,
мене запросили на програму EWLP.
Це — програма обміну лідерів.
А я займався різними інклюзивними проєктами
і просував тему інклюзії.
І зробили 5 пандусів, на це звернули увагу.
Ось у центрі міста, ну ще є, над чим працювати.
Це наш перший мурал.
Вірші старобільських поетів.
У нас в бібліотеці працюють люди
без спеціальної освіти, тобто я не бібліотекар,
SMMщик взагалі вчився в педагогічному університеті.
Тобто, всі ми без бібліотечної освіти,
але працюємо всі бібліотекарями.
Щоб бути гарним бібліотекарем — не треба вчитися
5 років в інституті і вивчати бібліотечну справу.
Головне, щоб вийшла людина, яка,
по-перше, досконально знає літературу.
По-друге, вона повинна не просто знати літературу,
а й повинна бути філологом.
Щоб людина розуміла основи психології,
як розмовляти з людиною.
І трошечки знати, як правильно
книжки розставляти на поличці.
Це все можна вивчити за рік хіба що.
Тому, якщо взяти в цілому бібліотечну справу,
то в нас дуже багато такого застарілого.
Переорієнтувати бібліотекаря, який пропрацював
у сільський бібліотеці 20-25 років,
і йому кажуть, як треба робити.
А я приїхала і кажу: «Роби так, щоб людям,
які до тебе приходять, було цікаво.
А якщо ти не читаєш сама,
то про що може йти мова?»
Тому ось хлопці і дівчата які приходять,
дуже багато читають.
Це найголовніше, читач знає,
про що з ним можуть порозмовляти.
Дуже цікава еволюція: спочатку, коли приходили
і знали, що відкрилась нова бібліотека,
то населення дуже складно реагувало,
на те що в нас українська книга.
Бо це принципово —
тільки нова і тільки українська книга.
І якби всі питали: «А російською немає?»
Але еволюція пішла і зараз
достатньо багато читачів,
нормально читають сучасну українську літературу.
У нас Старобільськ, воно місто — аграрне.
Тут багато людей, які займаються бізнесом,
пов'язаних із зерном.
Ось, таке місто не любить заворушок
і всього такого, воно любить тишу.
Тут треба засіяти зерно, потім його скосити.
В нас у місті все відбувається в стилі slow motion.
[сміється]
Коли ми почали виступати,
активно їздити у 2013 році ще до Майдану.
Ми їздили знайомитися
з культурою західної України.
Нас запрошували на різні фестивалі і
ми заряджені такі поверталися у Старобільськ,
і пробували щось тут організовувати.
Я, коли дивлюсь на своїх молодих,
вони всі сидять, уткнувшись хто в комп'ютер,
хто в ноутбук, хто в смартфон,
знаєте, так цікаво це спостерігати.
[сміється]
Тому що я пригадую ті часи, ще довоєнні,
коли я змушувала бібліотекарів читати газети.
Якщо ти не знаєш, що обласна адміністрація
щось сьогодні прийняла,
то пробачте, який я тобі бібліотекар.
В 2014 році приїхали якісь люди сюди,
мітингували за Росію.
Що то за люди були...
Були ще й місцеві...
Я думаю, що це було таке
«божевілля», якщо чесно.
Зараз в Старобільську вже набагато
більше патріотів.
Розвиток у культурному плані посприяв.
Класно, що в нас тоді активувалися
місцеві волонтери.
Чоловіки старшого віку, вони ходили,
патрулювали місто.
Я зі своїм музичним гуртом, ми їздили по Україні,
по Західній Україні, розповідали їм,
які тут у нас люди.
Тобто, займалися культурною дипломатією.
Розповідали, що у нас тут за люди,
давали інтерв'ю на виступах.
Тому що, українці з українцями були
незнайомі взагалі.
Для нас, людей зі Сходу, всі люди з Західної України...
Зараз вже не так, але тоді це було більш помітно.
Подяка хлопцям, які пішли на фронт і
ми не живемо зараз  в ЛНР якомусь там.
[сміється]
І подяка волонтерам, які допомагали і допомагають.
В 2016 році в мене виникла ідея зробити вечірку.
На платформі інтернет-радіо грає діджей, розмовляє
гість, а молодь у своїх бібліотеках збирається і,
за допомогою смартфону, підключається
до радіо і танцює в навушниках.
Ось ми зробили першу у 2016 році
таку вечірку для того,
щоб заявити, що Луганська обласна бібліотека переїхала в Старобільськ,
і вона є, вона — українська.
Коли я робив вечірку, я розумів, що я не можу
сказати молоді, бо я така ж молода людина:
«Чуваки, давайте в бібліотеку, там класно,
можна двіжувати і читати книжки.»
Взагалі...
Треба зробити якісний контент в бібліотеці і
тоді молодь підтянеться в бібліотеку.
Тому ми вирішили зробити якісь цікаві івенти,
антилекції, щоб це було так, весело.
Стосовно молоді — інакше не можна,
бо молодь хоче тусити.
Ну, в мене такий підхід.
Оце в нас таке невелике приміщення, але тут є
суперова збірка сучасної художньої літератури.
Кого тільки немає...
[сміється]
Тут ми проводимо різні заходи, тренінги,
вечірки, квартирники, освітні проєкти.
Тут збирається молодь.
Тут, як бачите, у нас читальний зал.
Тут ми і працюємо, бо приміщення в нас невелике.
Ось тут співробітники бібліотеки, мої колеги.
У нас є свій SMM-менеджер, свій дизайнер,
є райтери і івент-менеджери.
Таким складом ми працюємо і
організовуємо діяльність у місті.
Бібліотека для мене — це моє життя.
Книга — це моя подружка.
Головне для бібліотекаря — це навчитися читати
по діагоналі, як кажуть.
Бо інколи часу немає і все не прочитаєш від початку до кінця.
В мене залишилася звичка, що
спочатку я читаю книгу по діагоналі,
а потім, коли вона мене зацікавила,
тоді я відкриваю і читаю вдумливо.
Більш серйозних письменників,
щоб це було про життя.
Таке...
Ну, мабуть, схоже на те, що я пережила.
Тому...
[сміється]
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Назар Салабан]
[Аерозйомка
Сергій Татарко]
[Продюсерки
Наталка Панченко, Каріна Пілюгіна]
[Сценаристка
Каріна Пілюгіна]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Інтерв'юерка
Дарина Шегда]
[Режисерка монтажу
Юлія Рублевська]
[Асистентки продюсерки
Наталія Вишинська, Юлія Безпечна]
Анастасія Бондаренко,Вікторія Кравчук, Лідія Буляк]
[Субтитрувальниця
Юлія Леонтьєва]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Серія відео створена за підтримки Агенства США з міжнародного розвитку (USAID)]